live right now all I know okay sorry
actually left maybe yeah maybe uh
so I also need it here then on another
computer I see the chat right so maybe
people are watching us right now so when
will this oh he started following us so
this is this guy circadian he's upstairs
right now and he just started following
us he did he's not just talking to him
okay yeah no we are actually gonna play
him as soon as we we get this going here
I'm waiting to see if it pops up that
we're actually streaming is it good oh
right yeah I draw so we're just figuring
stuff I think it does right
why hasn't it we're not click refresh
click refresh okay no no so I'm gonna
play him but I'm just waiting we're
waiting we don't you know set everything
up in advance and then go we just hit
stream live just go go live and then we
figure out all the details later so if
people can actually see me this is we're
testing the live stream again to see if
we we got things going Tom it's gonna be
a few minutes but I will challenge them
we are live
excellent are the people watching
millions millions zero one you got one
person anything as me sweet but once I
get it up on my chest then we are in
business
oh here it is we are streaming now oh it
just takes you a bit of time super
official oh wait yes superficial okay
it's Akkadian where are you at
so this is some guy he came into the
Chess Club Jarek Milberg favorite it
tells me oh I got the inside scoop
favorite openings Queen's Gambit and
Sicilian defense oh I know I'm not way
you can blunder your paw immediately
okay always work
super raided time control honey that is
this is this this guy kb con 91
yes Acadian how do i is he also in oh
and i'm how much this guy you need the
chat to tell me how to challenge me
well if he knows that any challenger was
challenged to a game but I don't want
the time control real-time read it and
we told him like 15 that again
geez well we got a lot to test so this
this Josh this guy
right you log out of this um yeah just
like how did Bill wanna be impersonating
I am Rosen well we did that last time we
long now no got a secret
oh and that logs it has no no so yeah
you know right name oh that's STL
Archbishop's and then you know oppressor
yeah okay I probably have it somewhere
around look at look at the first Oh
yeah they're silly so I actually didn't
know the password yeah
so I'm here with Danny Huachuca we're
waiting for is Acadian nice assume we
have millions and millions of viewers we
got 45 45 wow that's pretty cool yeah
you just we just curious so yeah we're
just doing another test stream everybody
so is probably gonna be a pretty short
once a day so we're just gonna go slow
we're gonna be editing a lot of the
stuff on the screen because tomorrow is
when we will be playing with vara Cobian
so he will be here at 3:30 I believe is
the time yeah so far we'll be here
playing chess analyzing games so it'll
be the first time we get him on the
stream here so playing a super long game
aunt remember that super long it's gonna
be hard for me to resist the urge to
play so how how big is the delay cuz of
this there's like seconds it's like this
guy is in here in the club and he's
playing on his phone yeah so okay yeah
he said he's about 1,500 or something so
sounds good to me
so like I'm the chat I can see some of
the some of the words actually yes you
guys see wait yeah in the bog reach well
it's like we'll fill up one chat goes
crazy like I think so but like this is
it's disappearing too huh also oh the
pop-up box no scar already does CC
cleaner Oh fun
so the chat box thing needs to be moved
over to the left and read the whole
title they probably use a drop-down so
don't walk out yeah you have to do that
on this computer
yeah do you want to do any of that every
play yeah I don't know no cuz then it
will just show up on the stream just be
like fixing okay right so that
and also it doesn't look like any of
that stuff actually does anything
because I still has like just was very
awkward
so like some just says like new top
donator
but it doesn't seem to actually work
what are we doing here
placing waiting to move against this guy
you can't adjust you captured yeah
release attention
yeah I'm just have to move again we're
just gonna play not ready right here
we're just gonna play that theory we're
doing a little test here and so it's
okay there's only a couple swings so I
need to see the Chan out here I need to
talk to the people no okay that's that's
the important part right so we know what
it looks like yeah I was just focused on
that problem play barely know the rules
so yeah I'm just playing a really long
game maybe we'll get to play some faster
games at some point today but I just
wanted to say see what's going on can
you guys hear so we're trying with a
Yeti mic which I guess is off the screen
but if you guys know hear us they can
hear us every a that's fine
does this sound better I don't know if
anyone was here I barely know the rules
you were here
does this sound better than the last
stream and everything because we have a
new mic everything is fine here we can
hear you guys well okay that's good
nadia was just a little weird it wasn't
horrible the last time we were we were
doing this hopefully everybody has had a
good good holiday that's what's
important
get the layout needs to be funny stuff
here I guess I should calculate stuff
play funny woo and one of my ideas is if
if he takes this I can either take back
which attacks one of his knights or a
completely day for check take a special
that much won't work but I guess if he
takes me we're taking them back we have
not played a standard this is a
classical game it's Justine blasting
yeah yeah yes this is game in like one
eternity so yeah no the whole point is
we're just going to focused on this and
trying to get it to look right there's
really no reason to play can't this long
it's kind of insane all good the layout
seems to be under construction but
that's fine it is yeah but still
figuring out the skin okay that's you
talking yeah
so they can't see the chat at all what
what that thing is by the it's supposed
to be a chatting do you want anything is
like well I don't know I stream just
gonna take me a long time to fix it like
life's during the livestream I know how
are you today says himfox hi personally
I'm doing great I had an excellent
Christmas so it's like it has hold that
but then it disappears real quick and I
know Yoda says you know so it doesn't
seem to be here it's not this chat is it
it just wasn't Oh
the OBS OBS is being lab check and take
his bishop yes thank you it's this is
the start Dani Machuca he's our
behind-the-scenes superstar he's the one
that does a whole lot of the stuff and
he's the guy that's gonna make this
whole twitch happen this next year so
hopefully we do a lot of streams we did
one right before our break on the 25th
Lord we weren't open that day oh yeah
okay so yeah this it is this but it
disappears pretty quickly
okay so off to find like some studying
to keep it on there longer and make it
bigger on this side of the board I think
yes over there would be ideal because
then they can actually see everything
that's yeah so my screen my face kind of
blocks the time which is slightly
annoying to bozo I assume I just put it
actually in the corner that will don't
work okay and that bottom part doesn't
doesn't see me do anything yeah I don't
know how to fix it to answer more PM's
question this is our first time playing
a classical game
our official account here oh this isn't
my account this is the account that
we'll all be using when we stream for
the Chess Club which means so when bar
does this tomorrow at 3:30 central it'll
be the same account st. Louis chess club
I suppose they could if they wanted to
they could play on their own accounts or
whatever but the whole point is to get
everybody playing on one account so you
guys know who did challenge and
everything I can trade I can trade
bishops I draw arrows I can yes that's
cool
trading is fun wonderful yo we'll see
you yeah there's some delay and they
can't see my mouse let me see my mouse
on here yeah I guess you can yeah okay
train mighty little training I don't
know if I'm up pieces or down pieces I
just tread say I like the clarity of
mind like you took me oh you are up okay
also just like it just into it you know
I remember when you weren't I remember
when you were opposed to this yeah it is
our big you even made a video about how
I never trippy yeah something at that
yeah I was gonna make a serious here
with Danny about it's called traitor not
trade but the answer was always don't
trade no that's been out Danny has
convinced me that it's if justice all
about traded let me just bring your
stuff out trade it off it's a draw you
can this here I just happen to have one
a pieces of the process yes keep
training you're right I was down a piece
so I'm just be sure why not take on b7
yeah it was a question
I don't know cuz trade I'm off apiece
that's the answer also has a good quit
also probably rip the eight but I assume
he's talking about this position but
right yeah I can grab this my whole goal
here is just to not allow any counter
play I am sort of I need to develop a
living Norwich take the castle and bring
my merciless e-file um I do like winning
pawns though - if you would have
suggested it in time I would have done
it but in general I guess I don't really
want getting ready kind of play I just
like straight-up strange comment could
meet b7 could meet by rook b8 couldn't
me yeah Queen takes b7 repeated though
that could be met he correct yourself
okay okay yeah that looks like against
black counter play which I don't want to
do while I'm up a piece it's I mean it's
possible the computer will give that as
the best move because it was born oh wow
a drum it a 3 just subscribed with
twitch prime so this is a whole bunch of
stuff I don't understand I don't know
what like the subscribers are they're
kind of tears I don't know what any of
that is but thank you so much
Andromeda 3 nice ok his move to surprise
me yeah I'm gonna take this so that if
he takes back with this Queen I can take
this with check and then maybe I won't
say gonna be soon
was it so I can take no I can take care
if he goes back I take his rope
this is falling apart for our poor
friend now because he have 16 minutes
they're supposed to calculate a meet
here that's because you have you have
Knight to e4 19's fake and rook do you
want or cash taken inside and you
calculate triage calculate calculated to
help obviously yeah here thanks
here he looks like checkmate we're just
probably broken in it just rook t1 and
here there's Castle kingside Erza lying
in them it's all your pieces and they
get you in it or you can place a firm
well should we live so here's the
problem - what are we supposed to do sit
here and calculate like we also need to
calculate this that was my first idea
that looks safer because anything right
keeps running out there probably
actually calculating because they're
trying actually so what if you just
castle you'll see it please not watch it
doesn't great calculate anything see
even if people stream snake but you
don't calculate doesn't matter well
someone gave us 10 something good and
triangle this triangle spinner others a
10 cheer nice yeah so that was like 10
cents or something yeah we sure did
taste - what does that mean oh so he's
in first place
oh oh Ishmael kissing her nice cousin
here thank you very much sir
lamentation I even give us meat you know
counterplay yeah yeah yes I mean that's
the general idea when you're up a place
is when you're up a piece is not
to allow any car plate you're up a piece
get your stuff out and castle here what
I really should do if I was trying
really hard it was actually calculating
some mate or winning a queen or
something like amazing they break the
part Oh No but it's like a different
whoa hey oh that part worked oh cool you
guys can yeah yes nice know your name to
make it bigger though Oh what was there
like music is sometimes there's like a
sound when people do it I don't know how
people are lining up to show I do sort
of regret the time control be played
here but oh they stress thank you guys
everybody very generous today right he
does here
my understanding was that this guy is
1502 real life which might be true I
guess
this is called Bitcoin oh cool it does a
little guy running Oh cuz they fault Oh
is following us huh all right thank you
it's Akkadian who is yeah upstairs
somewhere I hear a lot of like people
stop it he must be angry up there okay
that was quietly have a hundred people I
do want to play some lung games today
cuz whenever they focus on adjusts so we
got somebody here maybe he's watching
our stream i'ma take a oh oh he gets bad
he's gonna go afk I think this was
happening before you are just this guy
oh we lost
what's up face dress I believe give us
some stuff 16 things in a drama no that
guy is giving us everything well you
guys are the best
okay a3 early that's seems like private
messages too it's my birthday
yeah hey oh cool I don't know if that's
is that who's that for me today
I don't it's not time-stamped dude I
don't think this is on the chest it's
just private messages to us okay hey
it's his birthday
give me your
my plan was just to effexor for the best
alright let's go my nobody's doing
though that's exciting or is just like
this I'm not sure
no real way to know what is going on
here
yeah and are those opening it off these
guys
can you challenge to us to a game yes
you can't yeah you can challenge me so I
am playing slightly longer time controls
today I'm mostly focused on watching a
chat I thought we would be during the
stream kind of updating things does that
make any sense to do does it does it
make me go see stuff what is that well
yeah maybe maybe it does if you're
playing slow games does that matter
you want to do something yeah okay so
also you can totally crush us today
because we're not we're not playing
chess today we're just is there anything
bad that we don't want people to see
here
behind the scenes of the magic hi what
is this this this is us testing because
tomorrow at 3:30 Central Time far is
gonna be here so we're just making some
updates to the stream here so we're
trying to make sure it looks good for
all you guys you guys deserve the best
thank you face dress he's been being in
the chat today gifted a tier 1 sub to us
do lunch bishops yes yeah this is like
stream-ception and they had said okay
something goes here so for people that
don't do anything let's just go back on
on Twitch this is what it looks like
behind the scenes so and that includes
us we're people that don't do much don't
wish you broke it
no oh someone gifted a tier one side I
don't know what does that mean I don't
know these people so at least you can
see the timer now no guard that's horse
fix that parts jacks small but now does
it need a rider scale it is it in front
of it has to be the front of things yeah
know that so the problem is that this
profile was set for like 1080p and mice
my monitors like 4k so like doesn't know
how to stretch it and I'm sure there's a
setting to like just scale it properly I
don't know I know where that auto scale
is that's why we got to figure this out
today yeah they're so cute thank you
chess was
hey Sean sup okay I am sure that you get
lots of fans but I want to say thank you
for taking a photo with me and one of my
students about a month ago you are
welcome
oh that's Ishmael Kissinger okay no this
game person nobody was what did he do
he's right there number three he's
number yeah I'm gonna go he say he says
he's been here yeah yeah yeah I just saw
his name because he gave us ten huh
dragna Lee's I guess they called
bitcoins bitcoins but bitcoin is there
that's what they're giving you given
using it looks like it does it's not
going to me it is going to the Chess
Club and you know scholastic chess in
general so is basically a donation to
any of the optimal discover intact
yeah they're called bits not
bitcoins on this other guy light that's
good
yeah you guys could also don't mess with
us oh the other guys just kidding so
yeah I was like huh
okay was I joking was that joking did I
mean Knight g4 Krypton
all right was Bluff extreme snake
testing the bits okay so we go to night
EG for now yeah hey don't say that
I knew that we have to test for stream
snipers that's also an important part
why assume you move first and then they
yeah I'd actual today are definitely
bitcoins that face signifies sad face
directly it's a Danny Machuca bitcoins
are into trash all right they're like
half what they were a year ago or
something we'll have to ask Nakamura go
see a big he's a he's a cryptocurrency
sometimes but he might be out of it now
for like a little bit I don't know he's
up to see just treating or didn't mind
that he hasn't been around in a while
Oh today's with the gout 4,000 right now
not actually up that much stuff here I
was last year is worth like 8,000 the
Clintons are only good for pizza mom the
the first Bitcoin was actually used by
like pizza or something for like a ton
what would now be like right for like a
million I'd say whatever 70% 75% less
Wow bias in general don't tell us moves
during the game unless it seemed
destined after the fact I didn't read it
I didn't read it before I found myself
they not actually up that much stuff but
yeah in general don't tell me before it
was I know it says plus one it says I've
taken this kind of things I do any
things for the Queen thing yeah
can you can you take them on it and
double-check
for you I didn't know if that was better
than fun I didn't know if that was
better than just bringing you my thing
recently it's a great time to get good
deals on some cheap crypto so maybe wait
a 3:09 65 that's how you saw it
this guy is always saying it but with a
delay we don't get to no idea me and see
this alright stop cheating just whiz
cheating is to be done by my co
commentator DNA only but but yeah for
both of you if we've played it not easy
yeah super no DS but we've adequately
all the time twitch bitcoin is different
from that okay cool
yeah I mean this is gotta be good for me
but it's a
that phone's hanging why'd you do that
sir I'm gonna take it
I assume he's gonna put a brook here but
then I'm gonna get out of the way by
taking yeah yeah I assume he's gonna put
a truck here but then I'm gonna attack
his visual you know the way I be able to
take his bum and then end up here and
then the brilliance whatever
down on trolls ambitious I think there
a fault I'm good yeah just wear this
yeah he finds all the moves yes okay
Oh Jonah three he's doing right yeah
okay next he's probably a text
he gave us on it doesn't have to be 15
plus faking a massage is quite a lot
quite a bit long but that's we can go
for that
I can go for it now so I guess I should
be like thinking a lot spending with him
first time streaming second time we did
a test stream it was mostly my cover
playing today I'm here so I'm just
messing around we're also trying to
update stuff so if there's anything else
you want to update on here okay if you
want does that make a sound
someone did we ask them that oh we won
with the best the one is a resigned yeah
okay next game what was it was this a
casual game or something or generic boys
change we've got 20 you got two hundred
and seventy nine points
do you take opening requests yeah sure I
don't play anything play the bird okay
oh they're saying good luck tender :
grow it up crash up sent me slaps oh my
god off whatever to think I know this
play g4 plays before it right here think
they mean exit yeah oh here not only
mints here how is he
you didn't hear is just that fast the
runner doesn't make any sound on some
some thought there is a sound and the
runner is also there no bang this
ballclub please yeah opening up opening
it up okay after subsystem their eyes
subscribe me subscribe it makes a sound
runner if they're following you is just
a runner I know sound okay and also you
should move the runner to like the
corner somewhere because there's
something where I should be here with
like I had phones on so I actually hear
the sounds that they hear not like well
then I can be then I'll know that
something happened to and I'll look over
there
well how come he doesn't this isn't
making a sound shouldn't make sound like
I should come out of here but there no
no no my computer probably I just saw
Liam turned off yeah but do I want I
probably want to want some volume on I
know cuz it
where'd you go to the bottom I'm sorry I
don't this is Danny's computer so I
don't wanna mess with too much what's
this is this says Yeti no click the up
arrow the headphones no yeah yeah you
better take over
be careful cuz we're only up 30 seconds
from what we started with in this game
we got to be pretty fast play Halloween
gambit there into sound there's pleasure
unlike nothing's making is that cuz this
doesn't have this in the background you
know I mean I don't have the stream up
on this computer oh why don't we just
trying to sound around here them cuz I
am on this stream okay and I'll hear 30
seconds like a dozen Gregor how do you
play this opening Parrikar say Italian
sure professional
yeah it's my help he's also one of our
guys that has given us some stuff so
sure I say if you've given us stuff sure
no I had a turnout
get the sound good
just while you're here all right remind
me Ishmael once I tell you
so P okay also somebody this means
they're like a light chess what
moderator or something what's the game
does enemies like a light chess okay
just so subscribers cuz the other day
we're up there at Perry saw this little
there's wings that exam dentistry career
upstairs barium is playing a game you
saw that that thing is like no abort
abort like a little play okay like it's
something bad or like I'm I guess for
maybe you thought that me later me
computer I thought I just met they were
like that
well that means a donator know they do
yes okay see I'm also gonna learn all
the things I always have questions about
but I'm like yeah now I can just ask
okay so what donated yes we're doing
with this one oh so the sound was offers
and that was like exactly when he did it
yeah make sure that programs on here
alright this time controlling you can
take more challenges and as little folks
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
biological one alright
you know Ishmael thank you sir I miss it
makes the shirt based on the Ishmael I
[Music]
don't really know what's happening this
came very wrong with your layout yeah so
we got we got like ages and this guy's
moving slow so is there any way that we
can actually fix this or no because I
know I have to look up like the settings
it take me more than just like it we can
fix that at that but the other corner so
the top window it looks pretty fine
right also also the bottom thing doesn't
seem to do anything at all like yeah I'm
not getting updated
nope I just get rid of me yeah get rid
of that and then the to check though and
we're gonna make the check so don't ask
for me
oh yeah well he messes with this stuff I
can just tell some Christmas stories I
had a great Christmas we did a lot of
things right this year
this is my advice for parents out there
with multiple kids I say don't don't go
one by one we did that last year like
here you open a present as they're
turned open her present and there's
better turn to the president then table
work out last year because then they
know just things like hey they got one
more present than me this president is
bigger than my present that sort of
stuff didn't work out this year we just
said you know what open your presents
ladies you know how to read it has your
name on it just go read it did yours
open it
that worked out very well I had I would
say it was the best Christmas of my
adult life
my kids are very happy we got great toys
Oh No oh so the thing the new follower
thing is updating or something it's just
like too small so both fixes scaling
okay yeah yeah I'm just buying
randomostiar fuse them with quantity
yeah yeah that's my advice
I say just open your presents go for it
everyone was happy so the scaling thing
there's some other scaling option
because I made the Box bigger okay but I
still it's still there
oh so you can see like a little bit no
that's what I'm saying like I need it
larger but it doesn't thanks ago I like
way way way back there well we didn't
doesn't seem to affect it okay like
there's some options somewhere that like
use large text or something I don't know
where that options what did I get my
kids
I've told I told last time on the stream
about how I got a nine-story Elsa castle
for my three-year-old daughter which was
obviously a tremendous success
hugely
as a gift and yeah it was a was the
story of how I got it for super cheap it
was it's a $300 nine story humongous
it's like it's taller than my wife
castle
it's almost has talked to me yeah I'm
511 it's probably like five and a half
feet or something this castle and yeah
tremendous and all the pieces were in it
it was probably a like return that's
just or that's why it was so cheap you
got it Burt
I was just waiting for Danny to give me
permission but ya know those fantastic
girls were happy there's also I also
have a one and a half year old daughter
Penelope so she also it was very heavy
for blaze we got pokemon cards he got
this gigantic box that it probably had
in each pack the others like 10 but we
got big box it has like 10 packs and
then or something plus a bunch of toys
how much cheap Pokemon cards cost
nowadays the gigantic thing we got his
biggest his big present was a with $70 I
think they're probably still like five
six books there's windows for a packages
and I remember back in like middle
school you could buy a pack and a 75
bucks for like a pack of like really 30
or someone yeah yeah yeah so I got
something cool similar to that except
for it's way cooler was staying
it's like box of it not like an action
figure like I don't know anything about
any cord there's like 801 no no right
and though I mean a hundred generation
right so and I actually have a
collection my mom has it in a shed
somewhere so where'd he get it now soon
Oh
original yeah and I had almost all so
this actually was was amazing that
happened at Christmas I didn't get very
many gifts but my son did give me the
best gift I've ever gotten
it was he knows the story of how I've
always wanted a Charizard because my dad
had one yeah like one or two packs and
you know I have like a hundred facts one
yeah and he got like a holographic
Charizard just by complete login you
know nice and he would never give it to
me what's up
all right there's young children
presumably on the two also they might
get me a lesson
no that's you so I'm just gonna keep
going then I don't know how to end it
when you're done done just close it okay
yeah I think just close it now you gotta
hear money my blade starts to the
windows thing equipped with a shutdown
and they look turn off the software okay
oh I'll try it I might know if
everything got work okay so Danny's
going off doing a a lesson here but he
he knew that I had always wanted this
Charizard so he he happened to get end
up with two in the packs that he got he
got two chars arts daddy's never had one
and he came to me and he was he was sort
of sad you know when he did it too but
he's like dad you know I know you've
always wanted a Charizard and I want you
to have this
it made me so happy he gave me you know
he had to when he shared one with me
which meant a lot to him obviously the
carton doesn't necessarily mean anything
to me but but ya know just this act of
generosity it just kind of you know I
didn't cry but it really meant a lot to
me what's happening here there's too
many options I could for example move
this night acted for example bring my
cleaning I could for example take this
here this game will be over in like half
an hour yeah
well I don't like when I have choices I
never pick well also now I can hear
Danny in the background so I suppose
this is the most direct Emily's doing is
he doing 98
probably good for him there I don't
think I'll do that one here if I take
care you can take it I can go here you
can go somewhere
yeah a big fan of calculating
you know move my night it's not that
creative
and Danny made me suck my fish up today
I don't know what I'm doing
yeah I assume queen J 598 that's fine
for him because my Knights still hanging
that defense against the checkmate and
now my clean would be attacked that's my
assumption yeah if I take care he takes
back I say oh that's good for him don't
see a tremendous follow up one more time
I think here thing here do you not see a
follow up I can now move this thing you
can now take that thing I don't know
maybe yeah so I'm a little a knight or
fly Bishop takes g7
Oh
to our
but see I'm going to close this studio
door though well that's fine I can hear
them they can hear me that's probably
better please anyway yeah I'm gonna lose
a piece Stefan yeah I sort of have this
argument with Danny whenever he's here
about sacking a piece I wouldn't really
take on h6 they're probably way back
here
I would have just moved my bishop back
and just played it safe because probably
just better there but with Danny
his philosophy which I try to emulate is
you just take it and it doesn't work but
it does work does it this will work
that's sort of the the theory here
behind all of this these are never
really second pieces but sometimes it
works
you
my piece is all the time might as well
do it on purpose actually don't know
what he's what he's doing there quickly
um you missed Knight g4 winning a queen
then we're sounds right the where thank
you for winning a queen do you mean g4
yes thank you for where
thank you for here yeah does he have
this which threatens my clean and bring
you a bishop here oh that was a bit of
hitting good Cal good call
that's from chickens triple o three
black did ya know that's a good call
and miss that good thing I'm not playing
chickens yeah this time control is a bit
much though I don't know how long this
dream is gonna last but but now I'm kind
of stuck here because Danny's guys
yeah 15 15 there's just too much though
in if Danny's here and I don't have
anybody to talk to you on you're playing
professor
also the whole plate of this was so that
Danny could sit here and fix up all of
this stuff on the side that you see but
if he's not here there's really no point
I'm just here because I'm playing chess
so also because this is going to be a
whole thing this whole next year so do
let us know if there's stuff that we can
improve and whatever it is we're trying
to make this next year sort of the year
of our of our twitch channel here
he knows about this now that's upsetting
so hey all right Danny shutting the door
on me that's good I guess I'm gonna move
my king with the idea the bishop here
Cannella met with and for something else
I'm missing the McQueen strip shows
Bishop c4 yeah yeah yeah Bishop c4 I
might lose my clean
yeah
ya know this is quite dangerous for me
and if I want to know Danny was leaving
I never would have left those are just
too many moves it is a bit of cheating
wait tell me unlike five minutes after
it's already off the board impossible I
always have to watch you on YouTube yeah
so we're trying to get into twitch
though now let's get a pardon thinking
yeah I don't I'm not gonna do anything
game come on please I don't get paid
extra to think so not gonna do it farik
what did M lucky do when I move this
close I holidays go Emma lucky
what do you what does that do he did
some cool command are people listening
to music or something
do you need to pay extra for the stream
no I did not
so I'm just doing it to test it out I'll
probably be here just at least for the
first few streams I might be here
tomorrow with var just to make sure if
there's weird stuff somebody's reading
the chat and stuff but but no I'm just
doing this to help out
take my queen okay so why can't I just
take this one I want you my down yeah
I'll be down to some stuff this was my
other option I think yeah I don't feel
like I'm getting crushed put me by him
commands haven't been enabled alright
what are these commands this is why we
need an e here so he can like so only
works at Danny's here when you guys say
we need commands all right bye
I'm lucky
so see if we don't have commands people
leave well it's this little guy with the
remedies keepo yeah I don't know much
about oh there's such stuff what time
control do you want to play I'm like
10-15 minutes you know something like
that
I guess I'll play a few more looks like
twitch stream is in the webcam seems to
make use of that resolution but the
light chess webpage looks a bit pixely
all right what's happening what is
happening
we've discussed myeloma trade I got to
be really careful here got to being
really careful here
I have to say I don't really like what's
happening so yeah maybe I'm just worried
and I don't wanna be worse than like a
game this takes like an hour
velocity we're an hour
fifteen seconds plus zero can also be
interesting yeah you can also just
challenge me to five-minute five-minute
is probably best at this point seen you
on YouTube a famous person thank you the
chair double-oh-seven
then nights hanging sir she felt like he
was playing a great game up until this
point but maybe he's tricking me what a
trickster don't trick me that's not fair
look no Tricky's please you tricked me
okay here we are they don't know this
guy's playing well that's not fair I
don't want to play people that play well
League
he is famous yeah a little bit
I'm gonna choose my challenge time some
people can play more can I keep my place
in line yeah I do still need to play
Ishmael
if you've donated something yeah I'll
play yeah I should make it something
between like five and 15 minutes this is
just this is just too much
I would say I'm very famous also chess
famous is like a very small pool Sam and
Lucky's never heard of me for example so
how famous can i really be if M Lucky's
doesn't know who I am absolute it not M
lucky
now that the screen is closer and I can
actually read your name is it mm masak
don't know just don't know take my stuff
make this even closer I can't read
anybody's names I'm also not very good
at pronouncing names
[Music]
so maybe I'm thinking of taking this
sort of stuff
no I'm just inking up going here with
some sort of tricky tactics here like if
he goes here I can take this thing if he
takes back with a knife I can take a
bishop not really sure
also we seem to be friends with with
lots of good players here Finn this is
Jonathan Lemieux anything yeah
maybe people are our friend Michael f6
next move f6 294 Magnus Carlsen is
pretty famous yeah hey guys pretty
famous I agree with that
okay you take my bun don't do that there
yeah so I guess I can now decide if I
want to go here
okay I decided I've seen some lessons
you've held on YouTube so for me a very
famous ungrateful thank you
Taurus 42 and then I've seen before so
yeah if f6 I can consider taking that
thanks Rex Magnus oh yeah hard to
impress Emma Lawson and if he goes here
then I say all right good zip what can
you do
yep no this guy's just personally
Jimena slizz first two games today yeah
I haven't seen the games yet um what's
happening
how's Italy this person anymore they're
too good for me I haven't seen the games
it is the world rapid and blitz that you
are talking about I haven't seen any of
it yet
so I could have taken this bomb by
chance I don't have to go back and dig
it so sad you crushed down the too good
for me don't challenge me if you're too
good
yeah stop let me alone
also yeah this guy's probably trying to
know I can't be seeing her train you can
go here and trade no all right
this guy's a GM no I'm not to answer the
question the the first GM that will be
doing this is tomorrow far will be doing
it at 3:30 Central time so farm will be
far Cobian doing the stream tomorrow
which is very exciting so that's the
first time we have the GM on the actual
stream I'm just using our official
account which has the GM title because
there's going to be all the Jim and
residents are going to be playing on our
stream starting with far tomorrow
that's true maybe I should lock into my
secret potential this is genome next to
my name I ought to play stronger I'll
consider playing stronger when I get
more coffee
yeah need to be tricky when you're just
playing losing yeah I agree with that
and just plain losing is what I'm after
that's usually how I play okay so here
we go
is this where chaps
yeah and that isn't something missing
this car for me
can you deal when they crush you
stop crushing me
miles of here here I just be confused
look stop it
I pin him in something's happening what
if I can yell is it
yeah
so crushing me
g4 he can play night xf3 yeah that was
the problem it's nothing to lose you're
already losing hello Nirvana Raymond mmm
also that's a horrible color I can't
read what's your name it's not Nirvana
nirvana Raymond also it's a bit far away
I'm reading a little screen but hello
sir
also I should probably get out of the
habit of saying sir cuz I don't know
anything about this personally but thank
you very much for watching in GM find
black pieces no he's playing very well
which I don't appreciate
know it when you play against me
and also how am I gonna adjust flank
this guy in a dirty manner if we're
playing with 15 second increment I hate
it
you're not assert my deepest apologies
g-49 takes f3 bro page 3 yeah don't give
me too many hints I'm not trying to
cheat that's hopefully Andromeda 3 it's
somewhere not cheating and I don't want
to use the jab as as a cheating vessel
here so that's another problem with
these games by the time I see it on the
delay you guys have already gonna be
good guys but well yeah g4 and I takes
after wave of h3 I see you know
everyone's stronger than me in chat
today it's all sad
but yeah if you're just joining us the
whole point of the stream was to test
the twitch speed and all that stuff
that's kind of broken all around me fix
all that up and stuff but Danny had to
go to a lesson so he's doing a lesson
somewhere talk versus g-force crushing
don't tell me stuff like that I don't
want to that's another problem yeah I
don't want the ends like that because
it's just it's really unfair to my
opponent I don't know if it's true but I
don't like it
this is getting slightly a long time hey
Welker was here in our last stream ah
here's this person yeah that's this
isn't gonna happen three-quarters of a
minute that one's not gonna happen
up next is Ishmael 5+5 casual wilshire
wanted a general rate that seems better
but really matter too much so we'll
place my own rules one minute that's a
day that's a day I would please you've
been around people I see their names a
lot you do lots of streams oh good to
know some of you guys pretty sure white
is not crushing here yeah I feel like
I'm not crushing just get some admins
here to enforce basic rules religions I
think white could be winning yeah I
don't know if X gonna do but I figured
out I'm sure there's something do you
want me to make it read it yeah doesn't
matter Ishmael do I mean whatever you
want it to be his finding on the mic
cover stream then we did a couple days
ago which you can't watch on Twitch or
on our YouTube channel he insisted one
minute only and rated three minutes is
normal that's my normal time control but
probably if I'm talking probably like
five minutes but three minutes fine hey
my work
we'll see I really don't know how much
longer I do have stuff to do at 3
o'clock so I'll have to wrap up in the
next 40 minutes or so I'll try to get a
couple more games in after this one
no this is good numbers are better than
last time we'll go 220 people so what
happens if someone uses an engine just
to find the moves in a critical position
like attacking or defending or the
anti-cheating tool is able to detect
that I doubt that uh they seem pretty
good on my chest it's always impossible
to be perfect but um you seem to work
you get refunded right away if you do
play a cheater I don't actually ever
report people but I guess some people do
I just played cheaters I just move on
with my life no you found a good move or
did he I know well thinking but no more
or less it seems pretty good on online
chess the anti-cheating I gave refunded
points all the time okay what's going on
g4 you can throw this check in if he
wants or not
something king somewhere came to the
optimal square wherever that is figure
that out there what's happening I'm
attacking some stuff I don't know I'm
not gonna figure it out and I'm gonna
end up playing it but I don't like there
should be three yep I didn't see but
should be three so much for me what do
you prefer
five five rather than ten oh that's up
to you yeah that's the same to me in
general I I do like if I'm trying to
actually win I always play without
increment or delay because it more of I
just play fast and bad sort of guy but
especially when I'm on the Internet
yeah yeah the whole line tres leches
debate I don't know I always uh I guess
I say like chess is that what I've been
saying I just say whatever and then
people correct me all the time and I
looked at heaven my bully chess is the
answer against the engines yeah for sure
but that's not necessarily what is best
for the viewers on stream like this some
for playing bullet I can't give any
insightful information not that any of
this has been insightful or educational
up to this moment
but I I could attempt if I had started
afresh without having just blundered a
piece early in the opening to offer deep
deep insightful knowledge
I checked okay
checked me
all right I expect him to check me now
to make a decision where I want to go
over here
you can check me I want to go up the
board
and it's supposed if he checks me I
don't have to I can go here but that
looks like a little square guess I'll go
here take one
you should stream more you have good
commentary skills I think thank you very
much the chair double-oh-seven
just getting into it it is something I'd
like to do a little bit more of
especially this next year when we have a
lot more going on on our to his channel
so look forward to a bit year of
twitching
this this guy's using all of this time
there's not a lot of time trouble when
you get 15 seconds
ha he's decided to go after my pond and
said enough fair enough
[Music]
this is the problem
there's some King moon for thing singing
I can go back tell us Ben
all right what to do what to do we can
just put my knight here
she's reasonable to me
you have these two passers though that's
like too much but okay here we go
Michael's here take some pawns he as
fast as I get passers both are the best
he's charismatic I'm a charismatic chess
celeb oh yeah
often comes down to pain of your
mousepad so I'm I'm playing on my
Danny's computer and he's got this and I
don't know if you can see it he's got
this super gamer mouse thing and it has
like a million buttons on them if you
guys can see that or not yeah it's got
one through twelve here so it's actually
like moves really fast the speed of the
mouse is a lot faster than anything I
played on so I think he's some sort of
gamer it's not really my it's not my
mouse so hundred percent used to it's a
blown would be interesting
I have two best mouse Microsoft wheels
optical mouse 1.28 yes I don't know if
that's really I don't know what that
mouse is like so it's hard to know if
it's a patrol unit or a real answer does
alley easy to a ya know anything about
these like mounts houses
I believe the spouses okay
the desk guy how close he is gosh that's
only three squares son that's pretty
close okay here we go
hopefully I push check
but man he's a lot closer my guys
they're so far away stop there's just +2
for white now don't tell me these things
comes again I'll not even know if that's
true but I still don't want to hear it
is is a bit cheating so check it out a
check
taking a bishop that's exciting
yeah I don't know what that would to be
honest it's one of the biggest Mouse
yeah I don't know if it's the size of
the mouse murders
I don't really know what it comes down
to this is for chess I guess I don't
know what the optimal thing is you need
for a mouse yeah Yeah right don't even
tell me that I'm winning because it is
cheating and I also don't really know
this drew I don't trust you guys but I
don't have to do anything
I just play my game here so yeah please
don't tell me evaluations or assessments
or anything because yeah even if you
tell me it not that will support the
assessment is that you know gives me
quite a lot of info wait a minute take
on here Lou's got it all right tricky
guy well if I take this though and I win
okay I'll take that win yes yes I'm the
best I win
would you car not know the best chess
mouse he might someone like that really
might I don't
so I also don't know what the features
are that you're actually looking for
like do you need SuperSpeed like you
know if you're playing Starcraft or
whatever video games people play these
days do you need usually in Mouse it's
like super fast four actions per minute
I guess I suppose that would help in
chess I just don't know how important it
actually is Stockman says you shouldn't
have blundered a piece in the opening
yeah that's what I figured I only did it
cuz Danny was here and then I had to
justify it in his absence it was sort of
a joke between me and Danny that is not
appreciated when he's not around okay no
idea go try to win this guy failing that
my goal here is to not trade pawns if I
don't have to get out of there please oh
wait
get out yeah yeah my goal is to not
train as many pawns as I can while
taking this guy running back over here
ending up with at least one more pawn
and a knight winning again that's my
plant my mouse is eSports FPS ml so it's
gonna be good for playing blitz slash
bullet okay yes I guess I mean it's all
about frames per second is that the
general just blitz advice
I suppose it I mean I suppose it must
make a difference I'm just well i
promote to a queue yeah
get over there
okay
I should wrap this up soon
okay
attempting to trade us a few pounds as
possible I'm playing without a mouse and
I managed to hit 2100 yeah on the
trackpad
there can be tough especially if you're
doing something like one minute trade as
few as possible yes okay so we've
concluded thank you for the game on
drumming up three and I suppose if you
guys would like we can do this we can do
that I guess I'm trying to see can you
guys see this on the screen if there's a
big delay so I don't know yet
Oh what does that mean Oh drama three
mics in the game yeah thank you
we can even we can do this we can
analyze I suppose yeah okay so this is
good so so much that's a theory I guess
f4 is the move here yeah that makes
sense
I just played something it's probably
none of this you know it's just as
typical better in this sort of opening
yeah g4 I thought might be better okay
but here we are we're on our own
h6 yeah Bishop e3 is probably what I
play I was here with Dani so I felt
compelled to take and this is sort of
our funny joke just between me and Dani
is it yeah yeah loses but it always wins
when you're playing under a certain
level of player not to insult Andromeda
3 it was there ok but that's sort of my
joke is that it loses but it will win
here actually didn't no idea what to do
wow I can just play Bishop III can you
take my piece and it's just this is just
good for me ok this actually don't
understand but all right if you say so
this is good for me
Wow okay and the position is just good
for me there's a lot going on in this
thing okay
I never have come up with that one but
yeah okay knew I was losing the other
things were considered secure I was
pretty sure lost 98 I thought I was
losing here right now losing well this
is funny cuz I like I keep losing theses
but then the computers like yeah life's
better but like not winning okay
that kind of surprises me and I thought
about here I thought he could take it
and yeah this media's gonna end up
taking this the computer suggestion that
if I have efficient top five
ah but then Queen g5 that's interesting
but okay all I saw was here I thought he
would go here and then I did see this
okay
and then I assisted this was better for
him so okay having an idea there but
yeah okay here which is also bad for me
I thought everything was bad for me
yeah should just move my bishop again
okay I'm super lost no ok well speed
through this yeah yeah somebody said 94
so yeah 94 that's super winning cuz you
threaten my queen and then obviously if
I take EMI my poor Queen and King yeah
so thank you for there that would have I
would have done it here I didn't know
what to do anymore make sense my move
doesn't cuz my G for stores
okay so I gotta find King b1 earlier but
I didn't yeah and I tell you I didn't
know how much better you were minus one
and a half okay yeah do you guys like
the analysis by the way where did this
d4 was right I can't believe it
yeah that move tricked me it was good
do you guys like analysis afterwards
turn off the engine a lot of leg okay
well must be through a lot of leg okay
all right so I guess no engine is the
bigger notifications don't think you
remember me let's read a note is there
too much leg when I have the engine on
is that ruining everything last year are
you going to come to the chess
tournament in Fenton tonight where I'm
not so system rounds at the Y no I
didn't know about this tournament no I
did not know I'd have to make my plans
to come there uh who'd I say where are
you - ma'am standard super rated this
guy donated so we will play him what CPU
he has so I don't know this is uh this
is danny mccooz what did they say what
did you want you wanted the Italian game
yeah okay so I don't know what's up here
won't play if you want one opening I'm
almost guaranteed to lose that it's here
I've never played it 45 and then won the
game I just lose let's just guaranteed
this is all probably some sort of theory
I'll follow the general advice of since
he hasn't castled when he plays here
I'll take it check out its liking cuz of
the engine right okay so no engines yeah
it's not working with that is everything
fine now
hopefully everything's fine yes yes it's
fine
okay all right all right no engines
that's actually good to know because
otherwise it would be nice to be able to
analyze some games for the critical
points where I don't know but if that
likes the stream it's actually about
okay
taking looks super ultra dangerous
that's fun to look at something to this
file I go here it takes or something
what's happening
orange very interesting
okay so it was legging but it's it's all
gun yeah
it caught up hopefully I don't have to
do stuff like refresh the stream or
something because I know I am gonna take
it because it Queen takes this morning's
fine now
excellent that steam you attack I
believe and I probably says somewhere on
the screen really it tells you like what
opening you're actually doing oh he took
that fast o.o get some trick here
oh no he took that fast okay yeah still
don't know what's going on oh cuz I
don't know how these things work
once you go here so maybe to play here
that would stop me that one knows
yes
you can analyze without engine turning
on for a couple of seconds just to see
it move that's a good idea so if I it's
good to know that I didn't know if I
turned it on for a long time it just
likes a stream I don't know if there's a
way to make the engine weaker but okay
I'll just I can turn it on for a few
seconds but not for the whole time which
does kind of ruin it partially but
okay so what if we got here I am of a
pun that's exciting
still position I don't understand that's
not so exciting
okay what to do
so you're just gonna go here huh
this guy's scary hopefully here
I don't know this pond might end up
being weak he's gonna play here he's
gonna bring his works in yeah brings it
in right away
yeah so if I cook here
I got here he takes this and I take this
check and he moves away I'll be confused
here he goes here I'll be confused
you know what to do what to do it's sort
of Kennedy he can also set count of
course to use stockfish yeah I don't
know how to do any of that Danny is the
technical guy but he's he's left I'm
waiting for him to come back so we can
end this thing I don't really know how
to end it without Danny and he said just
shut the computer and I don't think he
was joking but it's not 100% what I want
to do when you go there who really wants
to play here
okay
just unpinning I'm also preventing this
if that's his idea his idea is just to
go here and then target this guy and I
didn't see that I did go out for I was
gonna take it what's happening takes
he's playing Warcraft one miss bishops
attacked hey what are you doing is this
guy doing good option don't get your
computer to run the analysis choose to
run it server side that just an option I
have on HS Thank You PJ w7 pro what's
with all the double of sevens
everyone has like demo no seven is that
some twitch joke I'm unaware of
you check me
so yeah there's still tons to figure out
I was hoping to just figure out today
all the stuff like making the screen
good and the check good pulled out
Danny's help we can't do any of that
also how's my hair these days it's
probably about time I start looking into
how my hair looks for the day
that cloud analysis is only four known
positions on the cards and games
so muscle thinking about my upcoming
challenges I'd like to do maybe one more
after this I go here he traits to
sponsor me hanging
some trade here this things can be
hanging
I'm under a little bit of pressure what
well then I can't go back now I'd be
fine
but yeah thank you guys for staying with
us and being so good and chat and yeah
any any suggestions you guys have helps
a lot
yeah we're here tomorrow with bar
hopefully I get the fun job tomorrow I'm
just sitting at the desk talking
nonsense with the chat the bar has to do
all this the hard part the chess Park
it's so complicated yeah
what is happening here look some ponds
he does have some slight pressure here
that's the only thing going on but the
eye should be
no this guy and he's all my stuff
some smart a five stuff bring them in
pay attention to where this guy's going
I guess I would like to go here in an
attempt to win this fun don't bring my
guy in first
also without anybody here and the thing
how do I get my I'm gonna get my water a
sore throat
I think people around me need to be
constantly surrounded by humans what's
he doing I don't know what he's doing
which I don't like when I don't know
what they're doing because then
sometimes I just check maybe they put
all their pieces by my king and then
they check my me I know what they were
doing so it works
okay who put this guy here
with our Bishop on this diagonal we'll
try to figure out if the cemre wins
apiece I've seen some of you ever use on
YouTube you're good at explaining chess
you can do that maybe while playing
explain chess yeah I can try stockfish
really likes this position but I won't
say which side yeah even that's too much
to know that somebody's winning is it's
also a bit like cheating mmm I like
chess yeah yeah don't don't tell me
things like starfish likes this position
etc does feel like a bit too much
information
I don't really want to do this though
yeah I mean might be good my win apiece
I gave a cheque minute
it's nicely you're doing live streams
yeah so all this whole next year we
should be doing tons more oh that's
funny that you say now any tips do not
panic under time pressure I was kind of
freaking out during the game yeah I just
go here I go
and also I don't think during the game
which also helps me free up all that
time for my brain to not freak out
but yeah seriously how do you deal with
time pressure
I wouldn't know I've generally been a
fast player I just the point is then you
played with a bad chest but it's yeah I
don't worry about who you're playing
just just play the best most every
position you just you know you just play
the best move you can go for the best
there's really not much more you can do
than that everyone is cheating probably
not so since we've been streaming chest
I haven't suspected anybody of cheating
which is very nice yeah I don't know how
many people are actually cheating on the
internet could be lots it doesn't it
doesn't really feel like it to me
maybe I'm just getting duped everyone's
been cheating no wonder they're beating
me all right
I could unpin then I won't be pinned
to a another teacher stream - yeah I'm
trying to get people into it so so far
it's basically me and Danny getting
everybody sort of into this so yeah
we'll try to get people if you have any
requests I don't know how many Steph you
know here but yeah at the goal would be
you know my comer would be a good one
Dennis the room would be good Perry was
here the other day he was doing some
stream so it'd be nice just to get
people of all rating levels so it would
be nice to get people even if you know
their rating is quite low just get them
in here just play some play some chess
I'd like to see all the other teachers
get into streaming my cover would
obviously be the best it's hard I've
never seen anything my covers done and
not enjoyed it to be entirely honest
make my extreme ok you got it
we want a game wow how exciting all
right the no analysis I'd like to do
just one more
and then somehow in this stream
I guess I could text Danny I could ask
him how long until your lessons done but
when did it when did his lessons start
can anyone tell me how long it's been
several people have taught it just love
also stream Eric Rosen Ben Feingold yeah
they both have great streams oh nice
reading guy is you know you
five-minute will get 5 minute ago
go play Halloween gambit for Christmas I
can't do it as black and thank you for
the game hello good luck good luck we
play d5 that's not my thing
usually I played the Sicilian over the
French and I've been playing this lately
Oh Malika's very Colson our one and only
1200 rated superstar plays it so I've
been looking at it with him lately which
means I don't know anything though I
assume the Roxy Brian is that supposed
to be as good against this particular
move order of mine based on this move
but you should all see yes I don't need
to know the uptime I need to know when
to anyone to his lesson because they
don't tell me when he's coming back
so that I can I know what when this
thing ends I need to know when Danny's
coming back and they expect you guys to
know not me
this would be tricky thanks thanks
that's all so this might just be good
somewhere
probably efficiency to
take it
they completely a five thank you no no
I'm just uh calm though is almost 2,000
online chess so yeah like chess readings
are a little bit higher
which I've always liked she's stupid
that was held for profanity and I will
though aggression ooh I love them this
time but they more we're gonna allow
them later
but Wow bands things based on aggression
I know that's pretty cool we have to
depart working I watched your king's
indian video defense cell in lecture and
it helped me a lot thank you for the
kind words and I'm gonna try to
pronounce everybody's name because
that's fun you get to watch me struggle
that was said by how you balls thank you
very much how you moles it means a lot
to me can I do this she were conscious
actually he took me hey there's no check
yet what's the castle and like it
checked me personally I always play on
the sites that give me the largest chess
training because that's what I live for
the highest just reading possible so my
reading on this site is I believe 20 to
80 my personal account this is if that
helps you guys you tax my clean it
just so people know we're about
I'm gonna work on the C file that's what
I want to do cuz I should do it the only
thing I don't like is you
Hey stab it Wow
what's happening here wait how long has
this been here is this a thing yet
that's the thing though right that's the
thing right right there I take a look
Vishal no son right
my winning enjoyed the opening tuition
videos thank you very much
quit detect no playing just take your
face though this is possible
something to go somewhere something give
me
I say sign me up for whichever website
gives me the highest chess rating
possible because then when I go to sleep
at night I feel better about my life so
if some site makes its own 3000 I'm
playing there I don't actually know what
I've done making a little deny see my
doing this but I assume this wins
but yeah I really should end the stream
after this but I don't know if I should
take seriously his advice of just
shutting the computer okay so take this
they'll take this do I ever have to
worry about this detect I can move away
with check so that's exciting he's gonna
take this thing what's it do I also
could just but that would defend this
thing
I have to be slightly careful here or
maybe maybe third peoples 1709 Ches calm
when they play over the board in their a
thousand rated yeah probably chest tempo
is your favorite protected eggs just no
chance okay I'm out of here sir
yeah this will fall I'm out
if he takes here maybe I can get away
with for anything a little checkmate
there's 1,900 feet a with 1309 chests
that come yeah it's always weird to me a
lot of people have lower ratings online
for whatever reason some people are just
better than or less than they are on the
Internet
well yeah I do ever like I am eating at
3 o'clock I can't do it let me text
Daniel and then we see if he's almost
done I call this
Danny Danny help I should work it what
do I do and actually want to hit this
dream yeah well no no okay well that
sort of into the stream with that booth
but well yeah I want to say thank you to
everybody are you still in the lesson
yeah yeah yeah we're wrapping it up
quite quick thank you in the game
everybody this button in stream okay so
should we just do it yeah the silver
yeah yeah
sorry for the quick quick quick come
back tomorrow at 3:30 central time wood
bar will be here do have to get going
now so thank you everybody for the games
we played today yeah